It's a hidden dragon world.
Wow
There were dragons when I was a boy
Where they went only a few know
Our story changed the world forever
We did it!
The world's first dragon-viking utopia
Your utopia, maybe. Mine's less crowded and more- ah!- sanitary
Hey, Bud, wait up!
Oh my gods
He's not the only one
She's a light fury
Oh, sorry
Did she just disappear?
Wow
It's a hidden dragon world
Toothless, go introduce yourself
Toothless has a girlfriend
I've hunted every Night Fury except yours. Hand him over
I will never give him up
Then I will destroy everything you love
We are no longer safe here. We all have to disappear completely off the map. We have to fight for their freedom
Come on, Bud
You're nothing without your dragon
Attack
Show them what you got, Bud
Yeah
Save him
It's you and me, Bud. Always